Prof: So I want to
continue talking today about
land use and the special problem
that we face in managing land
use and development in the
coastal zone.
Why the coastal zone?
Well, for several really
important reasons.
One is that it's under enormous
development pressure.
People often want to live in
urban areas.
They often want to live in
coastal environments.
But also, a coastal zone is
experiencing increased risk of
damage from storms,
sea level rise,
and increased pollution that's
also associated with density.
So I want to talk today about
the variety of strategies that
might be used to control
development in the coastal zone.
So I thought I'd start out with
a little cartoon.
Good news, at the current rate
of global warming,
we should be able to just swim
over there and eat them in under
five years.
So within the world,
640,650 million people live in
the coastal zone that are at
some risk of property loss or
injury from intense storms.
And the ten countries with the
largest number of people living
in vulnerable low-elevation
coastal zones include China,
India, Bangladesh,
Vietnam, Indonesia,
Japan, Egypt,
the U.S., Thailand and the
Philippines.
So that the overwhelming
majority of people that live in
the coastal zone in the world do
not have the capacity to manage
the hazards that they face.
And the variety of legal and
economic strategies that might
be used to prevent serious
damage is the subject of the
lecture.
So the growth of cities in the
coastal zone is a significant
issue to pay attention to.
So that on average,
coastal cities are growing
twenty percent faster than any
other cities in the world.
And they have ten to fifteen
percent higher densities than
other cities.
And of the twenty megacities in
the world, fifteen of them are
in coastal areas.
Now, within the U.S.,
we have a statute called the
Coastal Zone Management Act.
And the act is administered by
the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration.
And it provides for management
of the nation's coastal zones as
well as the resources found
there.
And it includes the Great
Lakes, as well as the sea coast.
And it's designed to balance
economic development and promote
economic development at the same
time that it promotes
environmental conservation.
So it has a tension built into
the mission statement of the
statute.
Now, there was great debate
within the Nixon Administration
about the structure of this
statute and what kind of teeth
would be put into it.
Should the federal government
get involved in the regulation
of land use,
the way that the State of New
York got involved in the
regulation of private land use
in the Adirondacks?
And there were forces inside
the Nixon Administration,
Republican administration,
you'll recall,
that argued quite extensively
that we needed to protect land
areas in the coastal zone and
that the cost to the nation in
terms of bearing liability and
responsibility for rebuilding
damaged areas was growing and
was going to be potentially
overwhelming.
So that the overall objectives
are conflicting and include the
phrase,
"preserve,
protect, develop,
and where possible,
to restore or enhance the
resources of the nation's
coastal zone."
We also have a coincidental
statute that's created the
National Flood Insurance
Program.
But that program is now
essentially bankrupt.
So the Federal Flood Insurance
Program faces major financial
difficulties,
particularly as the Gulf Coast
recovers.
It's essentially bankrupt.
The Federal Emergency
Management Agency officials
estimate that Hurricanes Katrina
and Rita together would result
in flood insurance claims of
about twenty-three billion
dollars.
Well it turns out that when you
total up the costs of emergency
response,
property restoration,
the healthcare requirements
associated with these two
storms,
it's not twenty three billion
dollars,
it's in the hundreds of
billions of dollars that the
U.S.
government expended.
So should coastal property be
insured by the public sector?
What kinds of alternatives
might there be?
And the Federal Flood Insurance
Program has encouraged people to
build in the coastal areas that
are at risk,
and it offers them a subsidized
low rate of insurance.
So that in the event of storm
damage, property damage,
flooding, the government steps
in and basically provides
low-cost insurance so people
rebuild.
So what are the variety of
management strategies that you
might use, the different kinds
of legal instruments?
Well, there are certain
questions that you might
address.
You know, how should we go
about protecting open lands in
the coastal area?
Should they be public?
Should they be private?
Should we employ land use
regulation?
Should it be managed by local
governments as it traditionally
has been through much of the
twentieth century?
State governments?
Or should the federal
government step in?
And I'll give you a couple of
examples over the next 45
minutes that will show you how
the federal government has
stepped in and applied eminent
domain to purchase up open areas
and resources that the
government thought were
particularly valuable,
not just because of their
ecological characteristics,
but also because they provided
recreational opportunities,
particularly in the vicinity of
these population centers.
So insurance,
whether or not the insurance
program should be continued,
whether or not the subsidies
should be removed,
this is an open question.
How about transferable
development rights?
I'll speak about this in a few
moments, but the idea behind
transferable development rights
is that you have a source zone.
So that if a zone is set up,
a zoning scheme is set up and
one area is more restricted to
limit development than another
area,
the restricted area might have
some sort of a scheme where they
could transfer a credit to
develop to another area or a
receiving zone.
So you might think about it as
having a sending zone and a
receiving zone.
So that if you are restricted,
you can't build on your
property because you're lying
within a flood plain,
you're lying say adjacent to a
wetland or next to the
shoreline,
then you don't lose your
property value.
So that this idea of
transferable development rights
does an end run around the
question about compensation.
So that it avoids the
possibility of litigation based
upon the Fifth Amendment that we
described, went through on
Tuesday.
So thinking about-- you see,
I've repeated insurance twice
here.
Thinking about the idea of
easements.
So that the government could go
into an area and buy up some of
the development rights but not
all of it.
So the complete bundle of
rights might be broken up into
bits and pieces.
You could also imagine a
statute that would employ a
variety of different tax
schemes.
They might be property tax
related, so that property taxes
could be elevated in areas that
are especially valuable.
And they might be lower in
areas that are further away from
the coast, outside of the hazard
zone.
And you might think also about
income tax credits.
I mean, what if you received an
income tax credit when you
purchased property that was in a
low-risk area?
Or in an area that had lower
resource values?
And also, the idea of payment
for ecosystem services.
Now, what would that mean?
What are ecosystem services?
Well, I mean,
the coastal zone in its natural
condition plays many different
roles.
And I'll show you some photos
in a moment that demonstrate the
flood storage capacity,
but also the biological
diversity is often higher in
coastal areas.
And also recreational
opportunities,
marine fisheries,
the commercial value of the
coastal zone is extremely
important.
Nearly seventy-five percent of
marine fisheries that are
commercially caught spend some
portion of their life in coastal
estuaries,
in wetlands areas.
And many of the coastlines of
the United States,
they're ringed by thin bands of
sand that are known as barrier
islands.
And these barriers basically
act to protect the inland areas
from intense storm damage.
So that thinking about the
variety of protective services
and recreational and commercial
opportunities in addition to the
property value opportunities
that most local governments are
looking at.
And why would that be?
Well local governments get
their primary source of tax
revenue to offer all of their
services predominately based
upon the valuation of property.
So as development increases in
any town,
in any municipality,
it offers increased opportunity
for a local or a municipal
government to secure additional
taxes.
So payments for ecosystem
services.
Now what might that be?
Well, supposing you have
someone who wants to develop in
a wetland area,
and you have created a
regulation or a statute that
offers specific protection of
wetlands.
And wetlands are protected in
the United States under the
Clean Water Act if they're
adjacent to a navigable
waterway.
But many states have also
adopted their own protective
wetland statutes.
And many local governments have
also filed suit.
So these areas that are
seasonally wet or marshy or
parts of estuaries,
they get special legal
attention in the United States.
So now imagine that you decided
that you wanted to curtail any
future development in a wetland
or an endangered species habitat
or in a flood zone.
Well, basically,
if somebody wanted to develop
there, you might give them a
credit so that they could do
that.
They may have to pay extra.
And that money could go into a
bank, basically an ecosystem
service bank.
And there are now banks that
have been created in the United
States and in different parts of
the world where developers are
developing in sensitive areas,
they're allowed to do that.
But they have to pay into this
bank and then that money is used
to restore resources that have
been degraded,
perhaps in the same watershed,
perhaps in the same
municipality.
Or the funds might be used to
purchase land to offer greater
protection.
And the trade is rarely
conducted on an acre per acre or
hectare per hectare basis.
Normally, you require the
developer to pay for protection
at some multiple of the scale of
the original development.
So it might be a one for three,
or one for four acre trade.
The developer gets to develop
one acre but then he's literally
financing the protection of
another area.
So this form of credit creation
and purchase and banking is
becoming much more common around
the world.
And if you think about the
similarity to this between the
cap in trade idea that we
discussed when we were talking
about the Clean Air Act and the
sulfur dioxide provisions.
Remember that in the Ohio
Valley and up through the
northeastern United States,
you had this cap put on
CO_2 emission
allowances for all the power
plants.
And that allowed a trading
scheme to evolve so that as the
ceiling for total allowable
SO_2 diminished,
it made the allowances much
more valuable.
So that those that emitted the
lowest levels of SO_2
received credits that they could
then sell to those industries
that wanted to keep polluting,
they didn't want to invest in
the technology,
perhaps a scrubber.
So this idea is very similar to
what's being discussed with
respect to carbon trading,
but also it has great
similarity to these other
concepts about ecosystem
services.
So that the underlying
requirement is there has to be
some sort of a legal threshold
that's easily identifiable,
and some sort of a trading
formula that is set up in order
for these to be functional.
So here is a suite of different
kinds of management
alternatives.
Now, as you think about the
vulnerability of property and
life in the coastal zone,
I want you to be thinking about
it ecologically.
I want you to think about what
principles of ecology or
understanding of ecosystems and
how they're structured and
function and how they change
over time,
what principles should you have
in mind as you're thinking about
selection among these different
strategies?
And I think that one of the
intellectual pioneers of this
idea of tying the science of
ecology with law that would
somehow control the way that we
use land,
it was pioneered by Ian McHarg,
a relatively famous landscape
architect at the University of
Pennsylvania,
and the individual that really
I give credit to for inspiring
me to do what I do with my life.
Now, I want you to think just
carefully about population
concentrations in the United
States.
Just swirling quickly here,
here's Boston,
Massachusetts,
Providence, Rhode Island,
New York City,
this is San Francisco.
So think about the density of
property and population that
lives in the coastal zone.
So that if you calculate the
proportion of the U.S.
population that lives in
coastal counties,
it's now over fifty percent of
the U.S.
population that lives in these
shaded areas.
And the areas of most rapid
growth include the northeastern
part of the U.S.,
particularly southern New
Hampshire and Cape Cod.
Also, Long Island,
but parts of Maryland.
And also Florida.
And Florida is experiencing
just a continued enormous
growth.
Twenty-five percent of the
vacation homes in the United
States are now owned in Florida.
And I'm going to pause here,
and I hope that this works.
I'm going to pause here to see
if I can call up Google Earth.
Because many of you perhaps
have not been to Florida.
But I'll take you on just a
very quick Google Earth Cook's
tour of the coastline.
First starting out in the Miami
Beach area,
and here, as we zoom in,
you begin to see the intensity
of development,
but you also are looking at a
barrier island.
This is one of those thin
strands of sand,
in this case,
maybe a quarter to a third of a
mile in width,
that in its natural form it
buffers the energy from waves
and storms so that that energy
doesn't normally affect the bay
shore over here.
So that this barrier island
wants to migrate in a landward
direction.
So this poses a really
interesting kind of a legal
problem.
If you're managing the
development of an Adirondack
mountain, you don't have the
same ecological dynamic going on
as you do here.
Because this is basically just
a big pile of sand,
and it's shaped by wind,
it's shaped by waves.
And basically,
it literally wants to roll over
itself in a landward direction.
So if you take a look at say
Cape Hatteras or Assateague
Island or some of the other
national parks that have been
established on these barrier
islands,
you'll actually see them
migrating in a landward
direction,
often at a rate of maybe two to
four to five feet per year,
depending upon storm intensity.
And in a natural condition,
in the bay,
you would see wetlands and it
would be a very active nursery
for a variety of commercial
marine species,
as I mentioned earlier.
But as you zone in,
what you can see here is the
property values in urban areas
have just gone so high that the
intensity of development is
really quite remarkable.
So that Miami Beach,
of course you have the hotels
right on the beach with the
cabanas on the beach.
As you move further north,
you see that the sandy area was
transformed into a golf course.
And over here in the Sunset
Islands area,
just think about what this used
to be.
This used to be a salt marsh.
And the salt marsh was
basically transformed by
dredging up the wetland areas,
the estuary,
and piling up that soil and
bringing in concrete and other
materials to create these
remarkable little communities.
So people are able to drive to
these communities and also park
their boats there.
So that each one of these
artificial islands has created
roughly seventy-five to a
hundred different lots at an
average price,
selling price,
in the 1970s,
'80s, and 1990s,
that was approaching a million
dollars.
So just to buy the property
alone, regardless of the cost of
building, would cost a million
dollars.
So that developers were given
the license to basically do what
they wanted on the barrier
islands.
And if you look further north
along the Florida coastline,
you see that the majority of
Florida's coastline has these
barrier islands on it.
So I was going to take you on a
flight over this.
I don't know if any of you have
played with the flight simulator
on Google.
But I decided against doing
that in the lecture because I
end up spending more time
underwater with the plane than
on the surface.
But here you can see the
barriers, variable in intensity.
But Miami Beach is probably the
most intensely developed barrier
island in the U.S.,
if not the world.
So I'll pause and back out of
this and head back to the
lecture.
And also, the development in
California, in the southern part
of the state,
is some of the most rapid that
we've seen.
Although the recent housing
crisis has slowed that.
Now, I want you to think also a
bit about technological
solutions, because there are
many.
Many engineering solutions to
protect against loss of life.
And following a very intense
storm where tens of thousands of
people lost their life in Great
Britain and also the Netherlands
back in the early 1950s,
a project was initiated called
the Delta Works.
And the Delta Works basically
built sea walls and dikes that
those in the Netherlands are
quite famous for.
And they're very effective.
So here's the largest sea wall
in the world.
It's triggered,
it closes automatically when
the sea level rises up a certain
number of feet.
And here's the Thames barrier,
designed to protect London
against flooding from severe
storms as well.
So that there are a variety of
different technological
solutions that are
extraordinarily expensive.
But given the property value
that exists and is at risk in
the coastal zone,
these are likely to be in our
future in U.S.
urban areas.
And think for a moment about
Hurricane Katrina.
Again, the low bound projection
of the cost is roughly,
cost of loss to the public,
200 billion dollars.
The high bound is closer to a
half of a trillion dollars.
And part of the loss was
associated with the failure of
the U.S.
Corps of Engineers to make a
decision that would raise the
level of the dike that would be
protective for a category five
hurricane.
They decided,
when they were choosing among
different structural design
alternatives,
they decided that they would
build a sea wall that would be
protective only for a category
three to four storm,
the reason being that they had
the authority to make that
decision by balancing costs
versus benefits.
So they reduced everything to
cost versus benefit,
and they basically concluded
that the probability of a
category five,
a worst-case scenario,
was exceptionally low.
Here's an example of that dike
breaking through and the school
bus on the bottom being flooded
over.
Now, a different approach to
this, rather than using high
tech solutions that are really
expensive, was being pursued by
the U.S.
back in the 1960s and '70s,
a legal strategy that evolved
in Congress to create a variety
of new national parks that were
then called national seashores.
So Cape Cod,
for example,
was one of the first national
seashores after Cape Hatteras.
And so that you can imagine
there were these private lands.
And the government was trying
to figure out,
well, how can effectively
create a new national park in an
area of private land or an area
that may be private land or
county land,
state lands?
So there's really a complex
mixture of different public and
private ownership pattern,
but no federal presence prior
to 1961 to '63.
So the Park Service was given
the authority by Congress.
This is John F. Kennedy,
who signed the statue and his
family being famous for their
home in Hyannis on Cape Cod.
The family has been very
protective of land use and
development on Cape Cod.
And conservation groups have
long thought that this was an
area worthy of federal
protection.
So that the Park Service was
given the money and the
authority by Congress to go in
and buy up the land on Cape Cod,
or part of the land on Cape
Cod.
And they decided to do that in
a very interesting way.
They decided to exclude areas
such as the village centers,
whereas they would buy up the
coastal areas that offered A)
the most recreational
opportunity.
Interestingly,
they also had the highest
property value,
so that they were in a sense
the most controversial.
So recreational opportunity,
maintaining the possibility of
public access to the beach,
which in New England and in the
eastern part of the U.S.
is extremely difficult to get
to.
So if you try to get to the
beach in coastal communities
here in Connecticut,
you often have a hard time
getting there,
because you've got house after
house after house,
and you've got fences put up.
So that even though the State
of Connecticut has adopted its
own law that demands public
access,
this is no way close to the
ethic and culture of public
access that evolved in
California,
as well as in Oregon and in
parts of Washington.
So that different parts of the
country have these different
cultural predispositions to
allow public access.
So one way to think about this
problem is to think about which
private lands does the Park
Service really want to own?
Do they really want to buy up
somebody's house or do they want
to buy up a commercial shopping
center?
Or do they want airports inside
the park or outside the park?
So there are many difficult
decisions that have to be made
if you decide that you're going
to use the power of eminent
domain to go in and create a new
national seashore or a new
national park.
So this was all occurring,
by the way, in an era when
climate change concern was
pretty much nonexistent,
back in the 1960s.
But it actually was quite
farsighted as a legal strategy
that we might learn lessons from
today about how we could manage
other areas in the U.S.
that are relatively undeveloped.
And if you look also at the
ecological characteristics of
the coastline here,
you can see the same kind of
barrier spit,
but in the natural form that
existed down in Miami,
at Miami Beach,
before that was intensively
developed.
Obviously, the density is much,
much lower here than Miami
Beach.
But it gives you a sense of
what an ecosystem like this
would look like in a relatively
undisturbed form.
So that the national seashore
now extends all the way to the
tip of Cape Cod up to
Provincetown and includes about
six communities with the most
intensively developed areas
excluded from it.
Now the Cape Cod formula for
land protection was curious,
because it gave the government
the power to use eminent domain
to go in and take private
property.
And eminent domain means that
they would be compensated for
their value loss.
And it was kind of curious,
because many property owners
realized that boy,
now that people understood that
the Park Service was buying up
private lands,
property values were going
through the roof.
So whenever anybody wants to
preserve land and they have to
buy up a number of parcels,
then it really pays the last
holdout,
because property value is going
to be highest.
And also, these rates of
property value increase were
occurring at about fifty percent
per year.
So many people took the Park
Service to court and said,
"No, we're not going to
give you our land,"
even though compensation was
being offered.
So what they did was,
they were playing a game,
watching property values
increase, knowing that the
market value that they would be
provided for the property would
be decided once the court had
made its final decision.
So eight, ten years later,
if they could draw the
litigation out over a decade,
when you have a fifty percent
increase per year,
that caused the Park Service
great anxiety and made them
increase their offer to settle.
But it was a much more
expensive venture that took a
lot more time to accomplish.
The Nature Conservancy has used
a similar kind of strategy,
but rather than going into an
area such as the Virginia
Coastal Reserve,
rather than going into the area
and telling people,
we're going to create a new
Nature Conservancy Preserve
here,
instead, they set up a variety,
a large number of separate
dummy corporations that went in
and purchased the tracts
independently so that nobody
really had a sense that there
was one group coming in and they
were basically creating this
collective.
And that whole strategy was
designed to prevent people from
delaying,
from holding out,
and trying to secure the
benefit that the increased
property value over time would
provide.
So thinking also about the
dynamics of this environment and
why it's different than an
upland area, say in central New
York or central Connecticut.
The energy that is pushing
against a barrier such as Miami
Beach or Assateague Island is
coming predominantly from two
sources.
One is wind and one is waves.
Actually, the sand shifts
around more in response to wind
because prevailing winds push
the sand up,
and the central stabilizing
force of a barrier island is
nothing more than a blade of
grass.
And on Cape Cod,
as just one example,
the kind of sea grass that they
have,
the dune grass that they have,
it often grows up maybe a meter
in height,
but it also sends roots down
about a meter in height.
So that it can withstand a lot
of over wash by storm waves.
At the same time,
it plays a function of building
up these dunes,
because it just reduces the
wind velocity in the vicinity of
the grass blades down to a level
--
I think I recall that it's
seventeen miles an hour,
on Cape Cod.
So the grains of sand are
blowing across the beach and
they hit the sea grass and they
settle.
The dune then builds itself up
under natural conditions.
Under conditions where people
are trampling the sea grass or
off road vehicles are trampling
the sea grass or developers are
building on the dunes,
you have a much more rapid rate
of dune loss and increased
instability.
This house is no longer in
place.
This house has fallen over the
cliff in response to a storm
that kept chipping away at the
base of this large dune.
And many barrier islands also
have a phenomena where they have
a freshwater lens of ground
water that sits on top of the
underlying sea water,
which is denser.
So that most people on barrier
islands as well as on Cape Cod,
get their water supply from
this groundwater lens that is
extremely vulnerable to
contamination.
And why would that be?
Because it's just basically a
huge sand pile.
So anything that is deposited
on the surface can easily
migrate beneath the surface.
So in Cape Cod,
they've now done a storm
vulnerability analysis,
which they've done throughout
the United States,
and tried to figure out what
the best response might be.
In some areas,
the Park Service tried to use
riprap,
which are big blocks of stone
that they put against the edge
between the beach and the sand
dunes.
And they found that that was
not a good idea,
because hurricanes and
Northeasters could pick up those
stones and basically chew right
through the barrier island using
the stones.
The waves push the stones right
through the sand.
So many people have started
building their houses on stilts
or refitting stilts and the
underlying infrastructure that
would be more survivable.
And many don't also understand
that during periods of intense
storms that these barrier
islands want to basically be cut
into segments so that they get
over washed,
and then as the bays behind
them fill up,
the tide goes down,
the water shoots out of the bay
and cuts across.
Here's a good example of a
house on Cape Cod that was built
on a barrier.
And the individual,
when he found that his house
was floating in the middle of
the bay,
he got his boat out and he went
out and put a chain through his
door and his window and dragged
the house back to the shoreline,
hired a crane operator to come
in and pick the house up,
put it on a tractor-trailer,
and dragged back out and put it
back exactly where it was on the
beach.
And the U.S.
federal government,
through the flood insurance
program, paid for the entire
cost.
So here's another good example
of the dynamic character of a
barrier, where the sands are
literally blowing through an oak
forest up on Cape Cod.
So that a natural condition is
a rare condition for a barrier
and the estuary that it harbors
in the United States now because
of the intensity of development
and the incentive that people
have had to try to make money by
investing in property in this
area.
Fire Island National Seashore,
by the way, is only about
thirty-five miles to the south
of us here.
And it's a pretty good example
of-- portions of it are a good
example of a barrier island.
And in 1963,
two years after the Cape Cod
National Seashore was created,
the Fire Island National
Seashore and Wilderness Area was
created.
So I bet you didn't know that
you were within thirty-five
miles of a federally-designated
Wilderness Area.
Now, if you live in a coastal
area,
one way of securing your own
protection is to try to capture
the sediment,
the sand that's moving along
the coastline.
So people, you can imagine that
this coastline was straight and
you imagine that the first
property owner in this case
decided,
you know, my beach is eroding,
and supposing that this was the
area that he was particularly
concerned about.
My beach is eroding,
I'm going to build a jetty that
will actually capture that sand
as it's being pushed along the
shoreline, which he did.
Well, if you're going to
capture sand in one area,
you're going to create a
deficit in the next area.
So that that is the phenomena,
this accretion and deficit
effect of building a jetty
explains why you have everybody
basically doing the same thing.
And I was flying over the
Connecticut shoreline last
weekend.
And you can see these jetties
side by side all along the New
Haven, the Milford,
East Haven, Branford shoreline.
Very interesting phenomenon.
But very expensive to maintain.
To build and to maintain.
And here's another example of
how to capture sand.
That's the Massachusetts Beach
Buggy Association that is
planning sprigs of sea grass in
an effort to rebuild the dune.
And it actually works.
By planting these sprigs of
grass, they can cause a dune
system to become restored within
a matter of a couple of years.
So the Cape Cod formula was
also applied to Fire Island.
And one key element of this
legal strategy was that if
governments at the local level
did not adopt the zoning
restrictions that the Park
Service wanted for those more
developed communities,
then the federal government had
the authority to use eminent
domain to go in and just take
over the land.
So it was a carrot and a stick
idea in a way.
If the local government did not
adopt the standards to protect
the ecological values of these
barrier islands,
then the federal government
would go in and use eminent
domain.
Interesting kind of
combination, is Fire Island.
Looking down Fire Island,
parts of it are rather
intensely developed.
Quarter acre houses,
sometimes tenth of an acre
houses.
And the underlying aquifer in
this case was polluted,
requiring them to drill much
deeper wells to provide the
community water supply.
I'm going to scoot ahead here,
another example.
Here is an example of a bunch
of fairly expensive houses
sitting on the shore of Fire
Island.
And because these are extremely
vulnerable to storms,
it's very common for this first
row sitting right on the beach
to be wiped out,
to be flooded out,
which is kind of interesting,
because it causes an instant
shift in property value on a
barrier when the first line gets
wiped out.
So here's another shot of an
area nearby, when you can see
the former house locations
marked out by these boundaries.
So that all of a sudden,
these become shorefront and
accrue a terrific increase in
property value.
Another example of a property
rights mixture on Fire Island is
the Point O' Woods Association,
where the land is owned by a
collective,
a corporation,
that then leases out the right
to take over one of the houses
in the community for a specific
period of time.
Could be fifty years,
might be seventy-five years.
And these lease rights are
often passed on down among
family members.
So that this has been an
effective strategy in this case
to protect the common space,
the open land in the middle.
By the way, you see also an
example here of basically
creating a seawall on the bay
side that would offer protection
for the houses that were built
here.
But to do that,
they basically had to dredge
out the material here and dump
it on other marshland in order
to create this developable
property.
Another example on Fire Island,
if you look at the little dot
up there at the end,
the Fire Island Lighthouse.
It was funny,
I flew right over this the
other day.
The Fire Island Lighthouse was
built right on the end of this
spit.
And you can see,
back in 1834 that it was close
to the end.
By 1909, the spit had extended
several hundred yards.
And today, the spit is almost
four or four and a half miles
beyond the lighthouse.
So that not only do these
barrier islands want to roll
toward the mainland,
but they also want to extend
themselves in the same direction
of the prevailing flow,
prevailing currents.
Another couple of examples of
pre- and post-storm.
This was Hurricane Rita.
And some of these were taken
down on the Texas coastline,
the Padre Island area.
Padre Island is an interesting
additional example of a national
seashore,
so that keep your eye in this
case on the structure which is
right about there.
So this is pre-storm and this
is post-storm.
Another example of high-rise
buildings.
And again, think about this.
High-rise building sitting on
top of a big sand pile,
structurally rather unstable,
pre-storm and post-storm.
And in this case,
you can see in the background,
there's almost no damage to the
properties that are on the bay
side of the barrier island.
Another example,
pre-storm and post-storm.
Pre-storm and post-storm.
This case is interesting.
Here's a shorefront owner who
was surprised to find that he
was now a corner lot.
So that this is a terrific
example of the way that a
barrier can get over washed,
and then the tidal flux causes
the water inside the channel
just to saw back and forth.
And this occurred,
interestingly,
on Nauset Beach in Chatham in
Cape Cod.
So that one of these little
inlets was created by a storm,
a northeaster.
And the sawing action of the
tides and the currents in
additional storms caused the
inlet to expand to be more than
a mile in width.
And the bay front that lay
behind it suddenly became
oceanfront.
And the new oceanfront
landowners were really upset,
because they now faced
increasing risk of storm damage.
So they went to the State of
Massachusetts and they also went
to the Corps of Engineers and
said,
"You know,
you've got to step in and
you've got to offer us
protection.
We're too vulnerable.
Our property's vulnerable to
loss."
And it caused,
now that they were no longer a
bay front but they were
oceanfront,
their shorefront was eroding
away and their property was
being threatened.
The Corps of Engineers and the
State of Massachusetts said,
"No, we're sorry.
This is a natural process that
we are not going to step in to
intervene."
So the U.S.
government has stopped building
these seawalls and stopped
building these jetties to
capture sand to protect private
ownerships.
Very interesting outcome that
has attracted a lot of
litigation.
Pre-storm and post-storm.
So I'm going to have to shoot
ahead here.
Let me close by just saying
that the central questions that
one would ask about the best way
to manage property in the
coastal zone include these.
Should the land be held in
public ownership or private
ownership?
If the land is currently in
private ownership,
how should it be taken into
public ownership?
Should the land be regulated?
That's a much cheaper solution
than going in and buying up the
land and using the power of
eminent domain or purchasing the
land from a willing seller.
How should we structure our
insurance programs?
How are we going to manage the
tension that exists between the
high property value in the
coastal zone that provides the
fuel to developers to want to go
in and develop intensively that
creates this public liability?
What is the requirement to
provide compensation when
regulation is being used to
protect one public good or many
public goods,
access to recreational
opportunities,
the important nursery
characteristic for commercial
fisheries,
the ecological value of an
estuary to store floodwaters so
that if an estuary is filled up
then it just means the
floodwaters are going to move
someplace else.
So that there are clear
benefits associated with
regulating development of the
coastal zone.
So that if you set those
regulations up,
should you also have to
compensate the private landowner
if he claims or she claims that
their property value has been
diminished?
So that these are the kind of
conflicting and competing values
that exist in the coastal zone.
Okay.
That's it for today.
Have a great weekend.
Enjoy the weather.